foreign
[Music]
we are solutions engineers at rstudio
soon to be called posit and we are here
to answer a question that we get asked a
lot which is can you use Python with our
studio team and the answer is of course
yes you can very recently I had to
answer this question so I'm going to
start by sharing a story with you I'm an
Indian national in order to be here in
the US to attend this conference I need
to get a visa and as part of the
immigration process I have to get an
interview with an officer where they ask
you questions like where are you going
what will you be doing so I told them
that I'm going to this conference I'm
giving a talk about using python with a
studio the officer said oh I know python
but I didn't know you could use it with
our studio so well
I told him that's exactly what my talk
is about uh unfortunately officer
Johnson could not be where he be here
with us today but if you're in the
audience we are assuming that you are a
multi either you are a multilingual data
scientist who has access to our Studios
pro products and wants to use Python
with them or you are an R user who works
with a lot of python colleagues and uh
you might you may or may not have access
to our products but you're looking for
ways to collaborate with them
so it is one thing to say that you can
use python in our studio products we're
here to show you how it works with the
use case we're in the DC area right now
and there is an active Bike Share
program outside called back Capital Bike
Share we went out and took the picture
um yesterday and it's this is the
station right outside of the hotel
as you can see that there are bikes
docked into the bike station
and when you go to the company's website
you will see a map that shows you all
the bike stations when you click on one
of the stations it will show you how
many bikes are available right now from
a live data feed
now what it doesn't tell you is how many
bikes are going to be available in the
future as we know the bike availability
availability varies a lot by the time of
day the location and we if we want to
have a smooth trip experience we want to
be able to predict how many bikes in the
future so because there's a live data
feed we um we can actually grab the data
store it somewhere and make a predictive
model so that we can actually know how
many bikes are going to be available in
the future that's what we want to do
if you are here at the very conference
back in 2020 you probably have seen a
talk that uses the similar data set does
everything in our packages
um it's actually from our colleague Alex
and so this this project has been
successfully running for over two years
so a lot of data has been processed and
stored as interoperable data assets that
we'll get back to in a second and and
there's a lot of data being stored and
processed when I joined the company last
year from more of a python data science
background
and Gaga and I started talking so since
we have all these data can we do
something different can we do something
entirely in Python and using our pro
products
and we wanted to do this for two reasons
number one well just because we can why
not
um well that's not really a good reason
the second reason is actually we thought
this could be a very common scenario
where in our Pro product customers the
teams that working one language may want
to collaborate with another team in a
different language using interoperable
data assets that's completely deployed
in the um Pro product ecosystem
so we are also thinking that the
conference isn't being DC so we actually
get to go to DC and ride those bikes and
here we are
so let's recap the workflow for the bike
prediction use case
um as if as in with any other project it
it starts with the data source which in
this case is the capital by chair API
and the data is refreshed every day then
the objective is to import this data
transform it and save it either in the
database or in interoperable data asset
like pins So based on the frequency of
the update then we have to consume this
data build that prediction model to show
the number of bikes for each bike
station then we have to move this model
to a Deployable location where the
output the predictions of number of
bikes can be shared with other
applications and speaking of other
applications we have to build a way to
share the predictions with our users
as if as in with the previous talk this
work is already available and running
successfully all in R so uh shufe and I
will when we were looking at this use
case we realized that we have access to
this data already in the form of the
database and the pins that the r ETL
process is updating so we decided to in
order to address the needs of a team
which uses a similar workflow where part
of the workflow is in one language and
part of the workflows in another
language we decided that we'll build the
model build the dashboards in Python all
within our rstudio products
so let's take a look at the application
itself so this is developed in our shiny
for python as you heard yesterday
deployed on our studio connect which
we'll get into in a second you see a map
of the DC area and there are circles
with numbers in them these represent
this cluster of bike stations if you
click into it it zooms in and eventually
we'll see blue circles that represents
the stations themselves the bigger the
circle the more bikes that are available
and if you click on one of the circles
it's going to give you the predictive
graph of the the number of bikes
available in the next 24 hours
so you heard of our studio team and our
studio pro professional products and how
does what are they and why do we need
them and how does python fit in here our
studio team is actually an umbrella term
for three professional products namely
workbench connect and package manager
as python data scientists we need a
place to start writing our project in
code and we need the environment to code
and so workbench offers a centralized
server-based environment that allows you
to code in your favorite data science
Ides so Jupiter and vs code
as your project matures you may want to
start sharing your content and deploy it
somewhere and that's where your rstio
connect comes in handy it's designed
exactly for that and allows you to
deploy a very wider variety of data data
science assets especially the
interoperable ones such as pins apis and
reports like quarto and Jupiter
notebooks and interactive dashboards
like plotly Dash streamlits and of
course our favorite and the latest shiny
for python
and if you want to install packages into
a centralized location
and that's not directly from Pi Pi you
can use package manager for that
so what are we are what are we going to
show you in the next few minutes is that
we're going to show you a workflow from
developing the model using existing
interoperable data objects in the
workbench and we deploy that to connect
and I'll come back and visit the
application itself we'll make a change
and it will update it live to the
connect deployment
so let's see the demo
as shufe mentioned we're going to start
with like we already have access to the
data so we're going to start with the
model building process so in order for
me to start working I need access to the
IDE so I go to our demo workbench and
Azure face said it supports multiple
Ides a controversial opinion I like to
start my work in notebooks especially
when I'm doing model building and data
exploration so I'm going to choose the
IDE Jupiter lab here and then I'm going
to launch a jupyter lab session I've
already launched it here and this is The
Notebook I'm using to train the model
and deploy it and as you can see I might
have to assuming a little bit more
cool so I'm beginning with all the
basics starting with importing all the
packages that I need in my work setting
up my environment providing API keys and
database passwords I've also built some
functions for repeatable code that I'm
going to use later and this is where I
start making a connection to the
database which has all the data about
the bike stored so this database is
being updated by the retail process so I
don't need to do the data cleaning and
exploration I can directly import this
data as a data frame in my python
environment and I can create a testing
and training data set and start building
my model so for this work we chose to we
chose the random forest model but like
another iteration of this work can be
building different kinds of model and
comparing their performances but let's
take two random forests for this one and
and now I've built the model I need to
test it so I create my testing set and I
compare the results with the actual data
what I have done here so far is what we
do every day as data scientists right
and maybe you all can do it better than
I did uh but the the next challenge for
me is to move this model out of my
notebook into a place where other
applications can consume the predictions
it's making and this is where I'm going
to use a combination of whatever and
rstudio connect so as Julia introduced
vetiver in her keynote yesterday and
also Isabelle gave a great talk about
using vetiver in ml Ops operations I'm
going to skip explaining whatever but
I'm going to show you how I used it in
my work so in order to start working I
will convert the random forest model
that I just built into a vetiver model
so that whatever can interact with it
and once I've converted that I will pin
this waitable model onto an RS connect
board yes this is the same pins package
that is available in R but now it's also
available in Python and it's used in
whatever for model versioning and once
I've pinned the model onto rstudio
connect I will deploy it as a fast API
endpoint onto connect itself and I'm
using the inbuilt function from where to
call deploy RS connect so what this
function is doing is I'm passing the
name of the pin directly to the function
and it's converting this function into a
fast API converting this model into a
fast API and directly deploying it on my
R Studio connect instance so you can see
right like from a few lines of code
under tens lines of code I was able to
move this model from my notebook into
Connect using using whatever
so I've done the deployment to save us
time here let's see what the deployment
looks like so this is my deployed model
as a fast API onto our studio connect so
I get access to these docs that the
first API provides I can see the API URL
I can see what kind of features it's
taking I can make a sample prediction I
can play with it here as this is API is
running on rstudio connect I get access
to all these features which is what
connect provides so I can like decide
who I want to share this API with I can
change the runtime credentials for this
API I can manage it here
what I've done so far is run my run the
model once on the current state of the
database but the r process is updating
this database every day because the
number of bikes are changing every day
so that data is also getting refreshed
so my next task is to update my model
with the latest data so that like it's
always available with the right data the
current data
so for this work I'm also again using
rstudio connect I Studio connect
provides you the ability to deploy a
jupyter notebook and schedule it so I'm
going to deploy this Jupiter notebook
using the git based deployment in our
studio connect this is one of the many
types of deployment available I'm going
to use gitbase to make sure that my code
on my git repo is consistent with what
is available on our studio connect
again to save us time this is a short
talk I've already deployed this notebook
on ask you to connect and this is what
it looks like the same notebook that I
had in my IDE and I'm going to use the
schedule feature of rstudio connect
create a schedule to run this notebook
every time the data is updated
all right so so far we have seen the
process of developing the model in
workbench and deploy to connect and let
it run as a notebook on a regular basis
for this part I'm going to show you the
app itself and we're going to make a
change in the app and we'll live deploy
to our our server connect server and
we'll see how it works so right now just
take a look back at the the app again
this time I wanted you to pay attention
to the color of these circles it looked
like kind of bluish just keep that in
mind it's going to be relevant in a
second
um I'm going to show you something here
so we made this application in shiny for
python it's very very exciting to use
this package and I learned a lot from
this and in fact I actually find the
documentation and this online examples
it's kind of magical awesome tutorials
really helpful and if you want to learn
more about it Winston has a talk right
coming up right that's next after our
talk so definitely stay for that
um what I wanted to highlight here in
the code is the interoperability that
really saved us a lot of time as Gaga
mentioned that we can actually use pins
the pins packaging art in Python so this
is the python pins and I'm reading a pin
that's generated by my colleagues Sam
and Alex
um this this pin was generated from a
quarter document that's running on on
the schedule so basically it takes the
the bike station information process it
and it stores and the pin and it updates
every day so I don't have to do anything
I just have to read it into a data frame
and use a data frame in my application
so it's really handy for me and at the
same time also use the vetiver endpoint
to use the Goggins API to predict the
the number of bikes
okay so here the next I'm going to show
you the um the the updates now I
mentioned the color right I don't really
like dark blue color it looks a little
depressing to me Gogan do you have any
suggestions yeah let's make it orange
one of our new colors okay so let's
change it to Orange all right change
made and so what I would do in this case
we're going to
deploy to the connect server and I'm
going to run it right now and we'll
explain in a second what it means so you
probably cannot see everything so I'm
just going to explain in general concept
first when you deploy the connect as
connect supports a very large list of
contents that's that you can host in and
you can you can deploy the content we
chose is shiny because we support it but
if you want to use streamlit or plotly
Dash these interactive contents
dashboards totally supported as well on
the other hand the the
connect server you need to specify where
it is so I'm going to just go to the the
app refresh a little bit
and you also have to pay attention to
the virtual environment because in
Python is very important you want
isolate your environment so that you
have a sufficient at the package
isolation and so what connect does at
this point is when you send the command
and it uses the RS connect package right
this artist python package allows you to
programmatically deploy the content to
connect using a command line and
it it wraps your content into a bundle
first and uploads the bundle that
includes the application itself the
requirements.txt so that connect first
will look for the compatible python
version on the server itself and it will
use the compatible version of python to
run the app and
um and uses the requirements.txt to
rebuild the environment so each
deployment is sandboxed it's it's robust
against future deployments it does not
impact previous deployments it
guarantees to run all the time so that
that is really handy for us and and at
the end you can see that there's a
success with a little green links here
and let's go back to the app again let's
zoom in a little bit more
see the orange circles right and if you
click on one of them and you're gonna
see the predictions so all right we made
a change and it's live on connect again
so let's take a look back at what we
just did
we started off with our base ETL jobs
that's been running and it's been
processing on the connect and we started
building python models using vetiver
pins
um all the good things in workbench and
we deployed to connect so that it keeps
running and we also used the content
that's deployed to connect.api in our
shiny for python dashboard to serve our
purpose to actually inform us with the
future deployments of future predictions
of the number of bikes
now what does it mean to you if you're
already working Python and you have
access to the ER Studio team
professional products well you can just
start using your favorite python tools
today there's really no need to wait
and if you work with python colleagues
we just showed you a very simple example
but I hope they can serve as a little
starting point for you to collaborate
and extend the capabilities across teams
between Python and R teams so that all
within the rstudio team what we can
offer and we definitely hope you can
take it to the next level than what we
did
so what's next for you after this talk
um we introduced a lot about our pro
products today so shofen and I and most
of our customer facing team is at the
lounge right outside the room so come
see us have a chat
um all the assets that we built and all
the code behind it we have made it
public and if you have access to our pro
products and want to start using python
there's documentation on enabling
jupyter and vs code sessions in there
and asshoofer saying you can deploy
multiple different contents on connect
so the deployment guide is also
available we also use some really
exciting python packages that we
introduce as part of the conference so
there's great documentation available
for that
and that's our talk thank you so much
thank you
[Music]